we're talking about the money everyone
give their impression of how you say the
mummy nearly money it's a long Spencer a
film that came out in 1999 20 years old
sponsored oh god yeah yes so the money
came out a long time ago we made an
honest trailer about it if you watch to
the end of this one you'll see what we
cut out of the honest trailer for it
because that's how this show works yeah
yeah it's Blockbuster summer no
beginning of last summer right is our
way of just having an excuse to talk
about big summer movies that we didn't
have an excuse to talk about yeah people
have requested the mummy over and over
and over again yeah yeah this is one
that I did not realize there was the
this fervent of a fan base I always
liked this movie but I didn't realize
like there was a whole generation of
people like this is a really key
childhood nostalgia movie for now I was
16 when it came out and I liked it I
certainly liked it and I remained very
nostalgic about it but I think you're
right what we didn't realize was that
the people that are maybe 10 years older
from us this is like their Indiana Jones
in a way oh yes there it is Indiana
Jones so so it is there at the end Jones
India Jones still a fine film yes
I don't think that if the Aeneid Jones
films had a screaming sand head in them
better know you be the judge
a biplane yeah there's a melting but
that was a real naughty front that
prosthetic there's a real yeah that was
someone actually built that yeah and
some PA hand squeeze blood through the
eyeballs this was in the five-year gap
where the the reach of Hollywood
extended its grasp as far as visual
effects went yes the limitless
possibilities are not quite so limitless
yeah yeah this is uh this yeah that
weird little stretch where whatever
effects house did Mortal Kombat did
everything and everyone everything had
that slightly unrendered yeah see ROM
adventure game look you know yeah it
just it was okay people accepted you
know this rougher kind of more
cartoonish look whereas today the demand
is that it's much more photorealistic
and if anything kind of cartoony gets
through yeah its cartoony is a fair word
I think to describe this film it's like
a fun live-action cartoon yeah people
are big and broad and crack and wise all
around each other and the plot is just
like get the thing oh look out if it did
come out maybe like five years earlier
there would have been a Saturday morning
cartoon oh yeah like with a really great
tailspin ask intro yeah who ever wrote
good well like Rick O'Connell figure
smashes through some drinks shoots
everything
it's also like it's like the perfect
hybrid it's like those are the perfect
hybrid looks like blockbuster filmmaking
got like big and epic and visual effects
it's the modern blockbuster in that
sense but it was enough of the
old-school mentality of like they don't
think you're stupid because I was
watching it and the first easily the
first hour of this movie is all
character development building out the
the world building out the stakes and
things up that would pay off later
getting you to like these people getting
you to care about them and then the last
hour is like mummy action and everything
and it's and it's you contrast this with
like the Tom Cruise one and it's just
like night and day another Tom Cruise
movie
like The Mummy the mummy looks like
almost immediately mummy do you know
about any of these people you just start
in the middle of the action you don't
get to know any of them and this is like
Tom Cruise he's in a plane crash this
world the prime example is the mummy
itself himself/herself
you actually know who it is they give
you the backstory of who this person was
so that when they come back there's a
little bit of meaning in that one who is
that woman you know what to expect your
call I don't think they tell you they
must have told us like she was she's
like trying to kill someone she made a
deal with the devil so that she could
kill two people who were already asleep
I don't remember I think I didn't use
the name an ox una moon again they make
they make her the same fake woman from
this original or the original fandoms
Egyptian pantheon of gods shot gods of
Egypt didn't work anyways let's watch
1999 anyway the honest trailer just make
half of the characters 9 feet tall great
past and present a meal and it's
anybody's legs feet and everybody else
it's old pretty good pretty so you've
seen the classic 1932 Boris Karloff
version doesn't ring a bell I have okay
Marcy Tom Cruise's dark universe let's
give that one to time to revisit the
only mummy film anyone under 80 has
actually seen and enjoyed that's found
the mummy the Brendan Fraser woman
go call the solution to every problem is
to shoot guns at it
every problem sand he may not have a
plan
you know who's talking about how hard it
would be the hidden bait effect on the
size of your Rick but Rick's armed with
the ultimate scoop us not if you're
really not a debate but our our biggest
critique I think of the film was that
you have a name like Rick O'Connell but
everyone calls him O'Connell movie name
but every yet O'Connell there's
screaming O'Connell through the entire
McConnell's like a high school 80s nerd
oh yeah protractor study also it doesn't
it's not an effective nickname it takes
longer to say yeah life's Rick is so
immediately the creek is too plain you
can't calm like Ricky that doesn't sound
right
yeah it could be perfect it's a
challenge I like calling you spinny but
logically Spencer Iost his loan just as
long we're not saying effort Spence or
just took the time to come up with a
cool name that reflects those cereals
like they always had names usually Rick
actually yeah Rick's a common danger I
think we don't just yell danger and
everyone will get confused yeah because
the danger was already there let's
thanks guys Plus has his middle name
yeah the Brendan Fraser had a Fraser
Fraser that John debates
[Music]
joining a mr. Roger accrued Arab stereo
to Solomon's Graham flex arrogant white
people on a quest to plunder another
culture sacred artifacts together
cornered we did have a discussion not
for the trailer just amongst us of how
many the movie that wants two thousand
blocks the planet deleted scene the
pieces that this film would have
generated Oh word to come out now
hottest of takes a lot said it is a
period piece and it has Britain in the
1920s and 30s especially in its colonies
and Egypt extremely racist and plundered
yeah all of the things so it's not out
of character for the time yes it's just
no point does anyone including the local
people the Arab people in the movie does
anyone question that these white people
have the right to just show up and take
whatever they want from wherever they
want like that's just taken as a given
like yeah if you go so the twenties
right just just pull just pull down the
stuff off the wall take the books spring
back to London with you you're good
you'd hope at least by 1999 a movie
could be like maybe some colonialism was
bad and my or instead of having the the
Arab character who serves as their guy
maybe you should just take all this
worst stereotype of the summer of 1999
that guy or Watteau
anyway time Wow I think this guy takes
it tie for life look at our smelly Arab
friend after the spoiler alert for the
Bobby after the air characters dies they
still make a fat joke about him in the
next scene the guy goes did you see how
he was they were very callous I mean a
lot of the characters the white people
were also buffoonish really everyone's
kind of a [ __ ] yeah it wasn't like
about their whiteness that they were
before they were giving them like oh
you're Americans know this guy
specifically just camel riding loogie -
no opportunity every opportunity make
him up he's barbaric he's disgusting
things yeah he's gonna literally smelly
he's a misogynist who's trying to molest
people like every awful stereotype in
one good got mommy
yeah that's keep go Phil unearth an
ancient treasure unleash an ancient
curse and they won't let you forget for
a second how ancient everything is
instant OSes ancient burial site ancient
Egyptian ancient Arab storytellers
ancient booby trap sometimes
accidentally resurrect emotive and
ancient Egyptian priests who was so
hated by the Fae ride that he gave him
superpowers for he would that eyes a
walking
zees a plague upon mankind and unholy
flesh eaters and the glory of
invincibility what happened to murder
his murder not work anymore
there had to have been a Dragonstone
type meeting where the Pharaoh was
sitting down like I really hate this guy
yeah like we could kill him I wanted to
die really bad and somebody came up just
like okay well there's a bit of a
trade-off here you could die really
badly but you're gonna make him into an
unkillable god yeah so that plans out is
there's like more about this unkillable
hide the coffin but don't destroy the
key hide it no one needs to know where
it is well know we'll put the map in the
key to the coffin in the key you won't
be able to wake him up unless you know
the chant with all the right words so
should we just not write those down okay
but we'll split them into two books that
said is there anything else we need to
cover there's the jar sir you know I'm
hungry
I mean lunch some beetles um if someone
should awake The Mummy
the curse to kill them should be like on
the next page
no it's being a second also in a
different location hidden butter fund
but that also is like it was like they
were planning like in 3000 years we'd
really like people to have to do a
scavenger hunt what do we do today to
guarantee that long after we're all dead
a bunch of people had to run around I
think this was an oceans type heist
together and they're playing the long
game yeah yeah that's a long game right
yeah let's let's shoot that film I'd I'd
watch that pretty cool before I'd watch
yes Jade Jade Emperor Jade Empire dragon
mm ho taps 11 yeah yeah I think is a
long con strap in for the 90s answer to
the Indiana Jones franchise that said
around the same time period in similar
locations on the same combination of
adventure I've been commenting like
Shannon I think about this there's a lot
of stories we get spicy there's nothing
you can possess which I cannot take away
[Applause]
has been saved for a thousand years
Brotherhood of the cruciform the
rallying cry I had to do it to keep it
safe and for 3,000 spired by classic
adventure serials which were inspired by
rain maple installment in Utah Jenny
along Sullivan's grave which were
inspired by pulp novels so let the mummy
be yet another reminder that nothing
you've ever enjoyed is original rescue
the damsel in distress kill the bad guy
here always has to do that at some point
you know just explain top doing here's
how movies work and here's the part I'm
going to play they're so afraid that the
audience is gonna say this is just this
is so predictable but they're gonna be
like we know it's predictable you need
me I dumped you first I think part of
the problem is that number one Hollywood
is progressively more creatively
bankrupt but the other thing is that
because of the internet now people that
we there's people like us that point out
all the things whereas when Indiana
Jones came out it was just like your
grandfather and the corner go like King
Solomon's Mines
it's a ripoff everybody knows because we
live in a world where the the the
information of eternity is at your
fingertips yeah I guess so
I don't think it's any more or less
creatively bankrupt than it was in 1919
yeah yeah have you seen the remake of
the moment this film though I give this
more leeway to like call out its own
kind of surface Ness than something that
was aspiring to be like a horror movie
or something we can get away with being
like I'm the big strong guy and you're
the mummy and I'm gonna punch you in the
eye and then he does it this is still
entertaining on its own terms just like
Indiana Jones is entertaining it's not
that it's similar to other things
because everything is similar to
something else it's how much are you
just straight up ripping off and not
even trying to make I wish I had
stalkers mummy ripped off Indiana Jones
me to steal from the best Tom Cruise
Indiana Jones it's like the most
surefire box-office formula of all time
yeah like they messed it up somehow yeah
they tried to get too much into it was
just overthought was dr. Jack averse was
just oh there was yeah you could just
tell there were too many moving parts
and it wasn't clear the idea wasn't
clear when they unveiled the custom logo
at the beginning even before I'd seen
the movie I was like this is not gonna
end this is hubris I was like wow
they're really calling their shot I was
gonna be a whole universe of darkness
and now we don't get to see it yeah the
dark universe logo was like the person
at the dock outside the Titanic saying
this is unsinkable
[Laughter]
from that point on kinda alright anyways
keep going buckle up and ride along as
our heroes track down a map that's
hidden behind a key which they need to
open some books look at the dead father
ancient foe tracks down some body parts
which he needs to find some jars for
this charge bring back his lover playing
an Egyptian in this film this is a this
is a Aloha situation that I was not
aware of how full Aloha Wow
story her father was a great
archeologist who loved ancient Egypt and
so he married documentary about people
who fall in love with banana married her
boat yeah there's just a guy who helps
us Ark so that was rejoice his father's
half pyramid like she's not the whitest
lady on planet and it's supposed to
connect her like she had descendant of
no I think that's the ideas that that's
why he immediately identifies her like
the vessel for an ox would you the code
I need at all no because it's Rachel
Weisz and she's beautiful and if you
woke up after many thousands of years
and were like I need my lady to be in
another lady's she'll do
the prophecy in a bloodline place you
guys didn't watch Mummy Returns really
dives full bore into that where she's
actually the resurrection of Nefertiti
[Music]
all of the mummy to just hit me I'm kid
but the whole thing is like Nefertiti in
an axe to the moon we're alive at the
same time in hey they were rivals so now
that all plays out in Maui to which is
very heavily about like let's put Rachel
Vice in Egyptian clothing and make her
look ancient Egyptian we could have done
in a comer goes but we value our sanity
yeah in kind of glam big attend to this
one quite frankly art I'm an art yeah we
got some big lips coming up gets me one
money at a time you like it you're gonna
get a lot of other things trust us yes
but you get one moving on Debbie keep
going a lot of here until next time when
we do the bill to violence
Barry Jones chick must have been scarred
at this point when I saw it because I
remember the bugs being the most
disturbing thing to me I mean while
everyone's getting mowed down so bring
the kids why are your eyes closed Billy
there aren't even any brains on the
floor it's not prying I'll make you
watch the Scorpion King I don't believe
this is this is from a porn Cinemax
porno yeah that's not a real movie its
Doom Patrol thank God Ventura courage
that cowardly do Darth Plagueis the dry
air Court Russell aftereffects sand
texture a shadow with the face of
Stannis Baratheon khakis 1001 Arabian
white no The Mummy is scared of cats why
don't all the heroes just a fee him by
covering themselves in cats
I can watch brendan fraser in a cat suit
that's a good question why don't they
just make the whole movie out of the
kids dance together
Chuck's the mommy that would be your
choices cat chucks yeah yeah yeah man
people people wouldn't screw with you at
cat Chuck's just waiting at a cat tied
to another cow lows this week because
the claws would hit you just as much
survival and I'd want to catch staff
like a bo staff that's how I'd fight the
mummy there yes how do you fight
somebody
we should smash that subscribe button
smash that bell ring that bells but now
we're at the ol new anti mummy cat van
what else is there to say about the
mummy a fun-filled fun was had by all I
like to be watching it I like writing
minute yeah it was a fun visit and I
also recommend Steven summers movie
before this deep rising if you guys
haven't seen it is a really ridiculous
monster movie treat Williams and it crew
I believe they're like a salvage crew
and they find this ship that they're
attempting to salvage but it's got a
tentacle monster in it you gotta be
intrigued William and it all the guy the
Cowardly Belloc guy on this is also in
that and like the same exact character
as he a coward he's very scared of the
tentacle that is though and I couldn't
place it to the whole movie and I was
just like why is this guy crazy pathetic
to me he's the guy in there will be
blood who shows up and says that he's
Daniel day-lewis his brother just like
tie drunk and yeah it's just like why is
this guy why am I not laughing at him as
much as I should and I realize it's
because of the darkness like oh yeah
yeah but speaking of carrots I reminds
me of a deleted scene we have one
question or another sacred artifacts
while forcing the locals to do all of
the dangerous work I think perhaps we
should let the diggers plain isn't just
when you're a movie isn't aging there
well
or rather no 20 plus year old movies are
aging well I think there's been a
mistake did you say steak man another
camera scan priest who was so hated by
the Pharaoh he gave him superpowers also
why I put a lock and key in the
sarcophagus your knees begging for
someone to release him what happened to
murder his murder not work anymore
starring sand blast from the past
the pagemaster chickapedia
the devil's advocate simon fares jarhead
and Industrial Light & Scratchy I like
sand on the rod another day another days
go we have to know once again proving
he's the king of awkward hand gestures
glad he's back you guys you know most
movies only have one cowardly sidekick
but the mummy ups the ante with three I
guess it was a special request by
Brendan Fraser that's a long the thing
is I can tell how well you know that
movie school ties yeah I can tell how
well you know that movie because of the
first chair to the script I saw the
whole thing and then just as Brendan
Fraser at the end of school times it was
like I don't get it that was
I'm an old guy that was a very mocked
moment from that movie when that movie
was relevant it's just a long time it
seemed like you're written you know this
movie would have been better if it took
place in Encino we didn't see no man
call himself the juice and I don't
believe he ever really doesn't say very
much at all he says waste juice yeah he
doesn't say we use juice doesn't yes
yeah publisher yeah okay there at
7-eleven and she doesn't need to polish
or polish or has the icing machine go
he's gonna know what's amazing and the
guy who runs to 7-eleven is the same
actor who plays the guy who runs the
library Wow oh my god you're right yeah
and equally he's equally a bad sorry
about that
oh god you're right and he's like what
are you doing and polishers like chill
buddy we just wanna waste the juice okay
and and he says no wheezing the juice oh
the juice and and and Brendan Fraser
says voice juice sweet juice is a great
fill sounds really good watch Encino man
Dan that's your next Brendan Fraser film
you'd like to revisit oh boy how so many
that I can't think of who wouldn't want
to be down for monkey bone
look if Dudley do is wrong I don't want
to be right man George of the jungle
okay
yeah I had some good stuff good
photography was he Joe Joe let me do
black Congo I'm positive he has fought a
monkey jungle baby monkey movies very
good coming from yeah this has been
fascinating this has also been honest
trailer commentaries long Joe
ban thank you come back next week for
something that's gonna go real fast
mmm real fast so fast gotta go fast
we'll see you that bye bye
[Music]
you